hello everyone and welcome back to the
champions showdown we are showing a game
that
has a lot of meaning uh for the
standings of the entire tournament and
uh well peter swiddler in general had a
lot to say
uh for the over the entire standings of
the tournament but we're gonna talk a
little bit about that later
as the game is very interesting and we
should definitely check it out
uh so without further ado magnus with
the white pieces opens with
d4 and just uh you know nothing out of
the ordinary here it's a
pretty weird position uh where we don't
have like both bishops on one side of
the board and both knights here
like it's a rook knight bishop knight
and here
the rook and bishop are here in the
corner which means that you can easily
just
castle here so here magnus opens with
the d4
and d5 by hitler but i will just mention
in the game
caruana versus alireza ferrugia uh fabi
said that he analyzed the game
afterwards
and that uh after firuja played d6 uh
karana just castled here and that furuja
actually
could gain almost a winning advantage by
playing g5 he didn't play it but it's uh
really crazy how
things like this can happen in chess 960
and
the reason is although it looks very odd
that this would be
close to winning as fabi said uh it's
actually
uh well very very uh straightforward for
example if white continues
developing let's say c3 strengthening
the center as the bishop attacks it you
just go
f5 and now you have
uh clear ideas of what to do white uh
will continue developing but
uh it's hard for white to develop and
it's incredibly easy for black to
develop you can
play f4 you can bring the queen over to
h5 you can bring the knight into the
game easily knight here somewhere here
and it's just a very very tough position
for white to play so
just to give you uh a taste of what can
happen but here switzerland went for d5
and
knight beat the c3 now by magnus we have
c6
and the immediate e4 so sort of a scotch
960
and by doing this you open up this
diagonal which swiddler will use as you
might
imagine from the thumbnail we have b6 in
here
of course you do not want to meet the
bishop the a6 check while
uh while the king is still here on f1 uh
you there would be no way to block this
you would have to
i mean give up a lot of material
including the queen okay you could block
with the knight however but it's not
very pleasant
so here we have castles and now bishop
to a6
saying okay your rook is under attack do
you want to move back the knight if you
move back the night then
nothing is defending your pawn but this
is exactly what magnus wanted
and here he gives up the exchange by
also grabbing a pawn so he captures on
d5
uh slither accepts the rook we have
bishop captures on f1 and queen captures
and now
if you grab then magnus just wins back
uh the pawn and
he he gains an extra pawn and we'll have
a
an incredibly strong light square bishop
uh for the sacrificed exchange so here
swiddler castles instead and the g3 now
opening up this beautiful light square
diagonal
e6 now forcing magnus to capture as
otherwise
uh spiller would just win back his pawn
so d captures knight b
captures and the immediate d5 making
sure the
the bishop fully uh becomes fully
operational
so e captures on d5 knight captures and
now
knight to e6 and now knight one to e3 so
magnus
getting a lot of development in for his
uh sacrificed exchange and
you still need to figure out how to get
this rook into the game and also
you have to play g6 at some point to
make this bishop come alive
so here rook to d8 you could also play
f5 f4
uh try to go for an immediate uh
aggressive
attack but sevilla goes for rook to d8
instead
and here magnus has a very very
interesting idea magnus played queen to
c4 here
but there is one move that is incredibly
strong but it's so counterintuitive that
it's uh well
incredibly difficult to find so you know
uh if you want uh have at it uh
well i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting such a
ridiculously hard move to find and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
b3 and b3 is incredibly strong because
it will take advantage of
black's dark square weaknesses which are
which are present because it's very hard
for
uh for black to counter this bishop to
b2 move also bishop to a3 is very strong
as this rook is still stuck on f8
and if you go for g6 which seems like
the most uh appropriate thing to do i
mean why not you if you open up your
bishop with tempo
bishop to a3 is just crushing
for white because now you really don't
have a good move and you cannot capture
the rook
uh and white will capture this rook
whenever white wants there are also some
very
uh nasty threats for example if you go
for bishop captures
then comes queen captures and now the
queen controls this entire diagonal
knight to f6 check is a threat of
winning the queen knight g4 followed by
knight to h6 is the threat of checkmate
so it would be incredibly difficult for
white to play this so
b3 incredibly sneaky but hard to find so
queen c4 by
magnus uh and now as filler takes this
uh
opportunity to trade off some pieces 97
goes after the knight
captures with checks hitler recaptures
and knights the d5 now getting the other
knight to this
very strong outpost queen to d7 and now
bishop to e3 so it took magnus
a few more moves to get this dark square
bishop into the game
but if you don't find that b3 idea uh
this is the
way to go so rook f2 e8 and now a4
now preparing a5 to open up the a file
for for his rook
and now finally g6 opening up this uh
dark square bishop
carlson blocks it with c3 and the bishop
to g7 now it's just a
much more natural square for the bishop
also you guard the h6 square so you
don't have to worry about any future
future bishop to h6 ideas uh with bishop
to f3 by magnus he also wants to
increase the activity of his bishop also
bishop g4 might be an idea and
at some point maybe trying to provoke f5
but here rook the c8 attacking carlson's
queen queen to b5 now offering a trade
uh
makes sense as you want to open up this
a file for your rook
but rook e38 swiddler says okay we can
trade but on my terms
now carlson goes queen back to b4 with
the threat of 97 check picking up the
rook here
uh so knight to c5 blocking the queen's
access to the e7 square a5 by magnus and
now
knight the d3 which is a very nice
attacks the queen if the queen moves
attacks the b2 pawn
uh also has some ideas of shifting the
knight over to e5 to go after the bishop
but carlson moves the queen again with
tempo queen h4 again going for the e7
jump uh but now svetler finds the
beautiful knight to e5
and now you can't go for this check uh
because after king f8 you just lose the
knight because if you capture the rook
captures on f3
wins uh wins the queen so here instead
we have bishop back to g2 carlson needs
to waste the move
uh to get his bishop to safety and now
rook the c4
again getting the rook out of harm's way
with tempo the queen is under attack
and here magnus just offers a queen
trade you could keep the queens on the
board with f4 but magnus doesn't mind
trading so queen e7
captures captures with check king to f8
and now
knight back to d5 keeping the
centralized knight here and putting
pressure on the b6 pawn
so here knight to d7 adding a defender
here
uh and fiddler calculates properly that
he will be able to win back the pawn so
a captures knight captures now with a
double attack on the knight here so
magnus needs to capture
captures on b6 a captures and bishop
captures and now of course wheeler goes
rook to b8 pressuring the bishop to move
and now he wants to win the b2 pawn
so for the moment carlson up two pawns
but svidler still up the exchange
and here bishop to d5 just moving the
bishop and allowing rook captures is
just uh great for black
so magnus finds the in between uh the
very nice tradition to
bishop to d5 attacks the rook pressures
f7 prepares rook to a7 to go after f7
so a lot of possibilities here and there
is
one possibility for example if swiddler
wants to
maybe simplify he could just try and
give back the exchange
with rook captures on b6 to give back
the exchange and win a pawn
and we would get something like rookie
check king here and now for example
captures on c4 and rook captures on b2
and we get this position where carlson
is up upon
but it's the bishops of opposite color
and uh well
it's it's hard to say if you would uh be
able to
to play this for for more than a draw
yes you will win the f7 pawn after check
but also the c3 pawn will fall so it's
uh hard to say if
this would most likely be a draw uh but
zwiller decided
to play for for the win so he keeps his
material advantage he brings the rook
back to c8
and now carlson again with the only move
that
gives white uh some edge to fight for
more than a draw
uh we have rook to a7 now going after
rook captures an f7 and it's a very
dangerous idea of course
if rook captures on b6 which is the
strongest idea for svidler then
carlson's idea was rook captures on f7
with check
king to e8 if you go here then of course
you allow very nasty discoveries
uh a rook could easily be won either of
the rooks
so king e8 was the idea rook captures on
g7
and now svidler would have to find rook
to d8
uh the the only move that allows black
to
to continue fighting because if you
capture the b2 pawn then it
then you run into the very ugly rook the
g8 check king d7 defending and bishop
the e6 check now forcing the capture
and after captures we get this position
where now it's a king and rook end game
but with carlson being up two pawns this
would be winning so
basically the point is that svidler
needs to find find this line with rook
captures allowing this
and then find this rook to d8 move to
continue fighting however
sevilla in this position on move 31
suffered kasparov's fate and
instead of rook captures on b6 he played
the rook to b7
he suffered a mob slip and the rook
lands one
square too early and it was in this
position that zieler immediately
resigned without even waiting for
carlson to capture
because now it's a free rook and i mean
again
so i believe these were the only two
mouse slips uh in the entire tournament
one kasparov suffered against fabi and
the one uh swiller suffered against
magnus
and like i said this uh game had huge
impact on the standings because uh well
carson of course was fighting for first
place
and uh yeah everyone thought that
carlson would win first place uh in the
final round carl carlson faced levin
arnon and
they drew the game so uh he didn't go
all the way
but uh svidler swiddler also helped out
because fiddler had a winning position
against nakamura who was also fighting
for first place in the final round
but in the end only got a draw so final
standings here they are
uh carlson and nakamura both with six
points
both share first place uh and uh it's uh
one of the
rare tournaments where it's actually uh
a tie that they don't have armageddon or
any sort of tie break so uh carlson and
nakamura are joint winners of this
year's
chess 960 tournament uh so yeah we
haven't had the joint winners for
quite quite a long time uh followed by
levan arun
in uh third place uh he he fought
kasparov and kasparov took a draw from
aaron
on day three very important uh draw for
for gary and
a very very uh you know important half a
point for eleven then fabiano corona
in fourth place with five and a half
also sharing with eleven uh wesley saw
with five points then we have maxim
bashar al-agrav who who got a lot of
points after starting the
first day with three losses then linear
dominguez also with four
and gary kasparov in eighth place with
three and a half
uh if gary hasn't hadn't suffered that
uh
that pawn that mouse slip against
fabiano uh probably
it would be it would be at least half a
point but most likely it would be a full
point
so kasparov in this uh in this lineup
almost on 50
if it weren't for a further mouse slip
then peter sviller with three points
also suffered a mass slip against magnus
and alireza ferruja
in last place with two and a half points
so there you have it that's uh the
tournament and the standings
i do hope you enjoyed it and this game
it was a really lovely game
beautiful exchange sacrificed by magnus
and the very very strong play by peter
uh in the end it's a shame it was
decided by milesley because
this game had a lot more play to go with
it
but yeah maybe we show a few more games
if you if you guys have any suggestions
do use hashtag suggestion in the
comments and i will go through them uh
maybe we'll have time to show
at least one more from the chess 960
tournament but we'll see how it goes
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank kim farnik
vashishta sri ramya apathy
evan and
andrea grosoni for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage
uh of uh the next tournament we have in
line it's a double round robin also
uh uh from the saint louis uh checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent start of your week